la politique avec la bataille à droite
pour désigner le candidat ump aux
régionales en 2010 quatre candidats en
lice gros plan aujourd'hui sur un
nouveau venu le maire de prades jean
castex jean castex son portrait marthe
amon johann lopez à ceux qui le
présentait comme un parachute et jean
castex répondait en catalan
l'atterrissage se financer en douceur
avec la prise de la ville de prades à la
gauche pour son premier combat électoral
il ya tout juste un an il faut dire que
ce gersois d'origine marié le catalan a
sauté sur le conflent avec un paquetage
bien remplie énarque il fut l'artisan de
la réforme des régimes spéciaux en sa
qualité de directeur de cabinet de
xavier bertrand négociateurs homme de
réseaux parisiens
il se présente lui-même comme une sorte
d'antithèse de georges frêche
on est là et si possible aussi de
dégager consensus pour essayer de
travailler ensemble pour faire avancer
des dossiers concrets pour nos
concitoyens si ça qu'ils attendent c'est
pas la dispute permanente c'est pas le
la petite phrase assassine le bon bol
fourni traité de con une fois c'est de
sous-hommes et c'est tout ça ça me
paraît une conception totalement
dépassée de l'action publique
à 43 ans jean castex joue d'ailleurs
contre le président de région mais aussi
face à ses concurrents pour la
désignation en tête de liste de l'ump
aux régionales 2010 la carte du
renouvellement des générations
c'est à cette condition tous ceux qui
sont indécis qui peuvent légitimement
question pas d'une élection pour dire
oui il faut changer
sadeghi et son chef de file sont créés
ces deux qui sont porteurs de l'avenir
du languedoc aussi son principal
handicap reste son manque de notoriété
sur l'ensemble de la région
cette campagne il amène donc aussi pour
se faire connaître
un placement à long terme pour un
candidat forcément ambitieux
[Musique]